in this lesson you're gonna learn how to
solve right triangles so what does that
mean to solve a right triangle well it
means that you want to find out what all
the angle measures are and what all the
side lengths are so there's actually six
pieces of information the three angles
and the three sides but we're only given
limited amounts of information here so
we're gonna go through two examples and
the first example we're given 20 and
side six so the first thing I'd probably
do here is solve for this missing angle
here B and we know that these two angles
here these acute angles are gonna be
complementary they add up to 90 degrees
so if this is 20 we automatically know
that angle B is 70 so that was pretty
easy but now let's say how do we find
out the side across from angle B which
is side B and the side across from angle
C which is side C well that's where
we're going to use our sohcahtoa or our
trigonometric ratios so let's see if
we're using angle 20 this side 6 which
is the opposite side and the one across
in the right angle which is the
hypotenuse which trig functions sine
cosine or tangent ties together opposite
and hypotenuse we can see opposite
hypotenuse that's asked that sine so
we've got the sine of 20 degrees equals
opposite 6 over hypotenuse C then what
we can do is we can think of this as
being divided by 1 anything divided by 1
is itself and we could cross multiply to
get rid of the fraction so we have C
times sine of 20 equals 6 times 1 which
is 6 then if we divide both sides by the
sine of 20 that will give us C by itself
so let's go to the calculator on that
one we have 6 divided by the sine of 20
make sure you're in degree mode since
the angles in degrees so that comes out
to about 17.5 so let's write that down
that was angle C 17.5 now if we want to
solve for side B I like to go back to
the original numbers just because this
is rounded here so we've got let's see
opposite and adjacent which one's
opposite and adjacent that looks like
that's Toa that's tangent the tangent
ratio so we have the tangent of 20
degrees equals 6 over side B
then what we can do is I can think of us
as being divided by one we can do the
cross multiplying to get rid of the
fraction so it's B times the tangent of
2006 times 1 which is 6 and if we divide
both sides by the tangent of 20 we get B
by itself so let's go to the calculator
6 divided by tangent of 20 that comes
out to 16 point 5 and now we've solved
the triangle we found all the sides we
found all the angles and you've got oh
let's do one more example so you can get
some practice with this okay number two
a little bit more challenging problem
and if some of this seems like a little
bit too tough for you go back to my
trigonometry basics video and that'll
help you to kind understand how to work
with the sine cosine and tangent ratios
a little bit better but for number two
we're given the side lengths but we're
not given any of the acute angle
measures so how should we approach this
well let's go ahead and solve for this
missing side here first and because
we're given two sides in a right
triangle we want to find that third side
here's where the famous Pythagorean
theorem comes into play a squared plus B
squared equals C squared so this is like
our hypotenuse that's our C side and the
Pythagorean theorem this is like your a
and your B so let's just call this a
side e here since it's across from a
angle E so we have e squared plus 5
squared equals 8 squared okay a squared
plus 5 squared is 5 times 5 25 8 squared
is 8 times 8 64 if we subtract 25 from
both sides of the equation we get 39 and
if we take the square root to get that Y
by itself we just get an exact answer
here of square root of 39 okay so now
we've found all the sides now we just
have to find these two acute angles of
course if we find one we could just
subtract from 90 to find the other one
let's go ahead and solve for angle D
right here so let's use again the
original values see if I made a mistake
here and then I went to use this side I
would then carry that mistake forward
that's why I like to go back to the
original problems the other thing is if
I rounded this like I did this on my
calculator got a rounded answer and I
use that rounded answer and then I did
the next step and I round it again we
get what we call around
or basically you keep brownie Ronnie's
gonna be a little bit off a little bit
more off a little bit more off like that
so let's position ourself over here at
angle D we've got the opposite side
we've got the hypotenuse which trig
function tell ties together opposite and
hypotenuse you can see that so or sine
so we have the sine of angle D equals
opposite which is five over hypotenuse
which is eight now whenever we want to
solve for the missing angle that's when
the inverse trig functions come into
play in this case the sine inverse
because the sine is sine inverse those
undo one another and let's see what that
comes out to on the calculator
we've got sine inverse of 5/8 which is
38.7 approximately degrees so that's
this guy right here and then if we want
to solve for angle E these two angles
add up to 90 so if I just do ninety
minus thirty eight point seven that's
fifty one point three and you solve the
triangle all the angles all the sides if
you want to see what happens when you
don't have a right triangle right we've
been working with right triangle
trigonometry that's when you want to use
the law of sines and the law of cosines
and I talked about that in that video
right there so follow me over there and
we'll dive into those concepts